[Music]
police say there were 300 at the illegal
rave in an unused railway arch
when the revelers fled they managed to
stop 78 of them
and gave them fixed penalty notices
they'll all have to pay 200
pound fines it's just the most
irresponsible behavior
and not only are these individuals
putting themselves at risk which they
just
don't seem to care about but they're
putting other members of the public at
risk
and my colleagues who have to get hands
on a deal with them
it's totally irresponsible but sadly
it's becoming the norm
officers sees the sound system they hope
that will help them identify the
organizers
who could face fines of ten thousand
pounds
after the raid the policeman in charge
captured the debris left behind
police have condemned the rave
describing revelers
as incredibly selfish endangering others
and forcing officers to risk their own
health
some of those who got away used a ladder
at a back entrance
there was clear evidence of the rush to
escape the police
one young woman returned to find
something she'd dropped
do you feel a bit guilty that you know
people are getting ill and dying
yes i do and i suppose i'm quite an
impulsive person
and i feel like it's going on everywhere
so there's a part of you that feels like
you're missing out
and i'm not saying it's something i
regularly go and do but sometimes you
just want to go and see what's actually
out there and explore what's out there
if you feel like everyone else is doing
it in the past week
police have broken up other raves and
they found 150 guests
at an illegal wedding party they insist
anyone at such gatherings will be fined
martin brunt sky news east london
you